diese bilder sollten der vergangenheit
angehören die verkehrswende war eines
der herzstücke der grünen agenda landauf
landab proklamiert
wir brauchen eine ganze reihe von
maßnahmen das endlich die verkehrswende
voran gibt in deutschland wurde nicht
nur das auto erfunden sondern auch das
fahrrad mobilität muss anders gedacht
werden weniger autos mehr freiheit für
die menschen und schon allein dafür
dieses verkehrsministerium zu einem
wirklichen
infrastrukturministerium des jahres 2021
umzubauen lohnt es sich am 26.09 grün zu
wählen doch wer für den verkehr grün
gewählt hat der bekommt jetzt vor allem
gelb die fdp hat das verkehrsressort
erobert erstmals übrigens volker wissing
soll es werden das sorgt mancher orts
gelinde gesagt für irritationen
frankfurt am main fast jeder vierte hat
hier grün gewählt auf dem wochenmarkt
macht sich ernüchterung breit
[Musik]
ich habe das gefühl dass sie sich im
wesentlichen dingen eigentlich über den
tisch ziehen lassen vor allem wenn es
jetzt um zb um die verkehrspolitik geht
das eine der wesentliche grund gewesen
weshalb ich die grünen gewählt habe dass
ich den wechsel von herrn steuer erst
mal total toll fand das jetzt bei freie
fahrt für freie bürger gelernt ist finde
ich wiederum auch nicht wirklich
zielführend geht immer um geld und um
wirtschaft und dann glaube ich hat so
eine fdp eine stärkere lobby und das
muss müssen die grünen auch einsehen
einsehen müssen die grünen wohl dass die
verkehrswende abgeblasen ist das zeigt
der vergleich zwischen grünen
wahlprogramm und koalitionsvertrag
thema fahrrad wende deutschland wird
fahrradland heißt es im wahlprogramm die
anzahl der radwege soll verdoppelt
werden im koalitionsvertrag bleibt davon
die vorhandenen mittel werden wir
absichern also bewahren des status quo
thema diesel subventionen aus beenden im
wahlprogramm wird überprüfen im
koalitionsvertrag
und aus dem tempolimit von 130 km h
wurde ein tempolimit wird es nicht geben
sucht man auf den 177 seiten den begriff
verkehrswende stellt man überrascht fest
keine treffer die wende gibt es nicht
mehr
omid nouripour wird als grüner
parteichef gehandelt
erklärungsversuche ich glaube dass eine
wende keine wende ist wenn man einfach
nur davon spricht dass es sie geben soll
sondern es geht um die instrumente und
da sind einige starke punkte die auch
eine mobilitäts werden damit sich
bringen im koalitionsvertrag verankert
dem sondierungs papier hatte die grüne
basis noch brav zugestimmt doch jetzt
macht sich unmut breit eine zustimmung
zum koalitionsvertrag
ungewissen alles was nicht geht es
konkret alles was gehen könnte ist sehr
schwammig mit worthülsen schöne worte
aber eben leere worte auch oft daniel
sevilla nie hat eine petition gegen den
koalitionsvertrag gestartet mehr als 600
mitglieder unterstützen bereits die
rebellion der basis als ich das verkehrs
kapitel im koalitionsvertrag gelesen
habe war ich persönlich sehr enttäuscht
und ernüchtert habe mich dann auch mit
parteifreunden ausgetauscht dieses alles
ähnlich gesehen haben
und hat deshalb gesagt ich muss jetzt
was tun und doch jetzt steuert den
verkehr in deutschland die fdp wie
konnte das passieren
im politischen berlin kursieren die
theorien mancher beobachter mutmaßt die
grünen hätten freiwillig auf das
verkehrsministerium verzichtet streben
nach macht und prestige
macht deshalb das ministerium das wohl
dann hätte getauscht werden müssen hat
einen anderen
machtanspruch ein anderes machtgefüge
als das verkehrsministerium bei prestige
kann man sagen die designierte
außenministerin
annalena baerbock die ja noch mehr
werden will oder zumindest das bleiben
will was sie ist das ist gesicherte im
außenministerium als etwa im
verkehrsministerium haben die grünen das
verkehrsministerium kampflos den
liberalen überlassen weil mit dem
ressort seit jahrzehnten nichts zu
gewinnen ist
die erfolglosigkeit der
letzten fünf jahrzehnte von den
bundesdeutschen
verkehrsministern ist geradezu legende
der verzicht war natürlich klammheimlich
sie können nicht offen als die klima
partei sagen verkehrspolitik
interessiert uns nicht
fest steht die grünen haben ein
schlüssel ressort verloren die liberalen
dagegen können mit sich zufrieden sein
oliver luksic hat für die fdp verhandelt
das kapitel verkehr im koalitionsvertrag
trägt seine handschrift die fdp ist froh
dass wir im verkehr
technologieoffenheit im großen und
ganzen drin haben wir haben sehr viele
aspekte zur dekarbonisierung
digitalisierung und vernetzung der
verkehrsträger drin ein aus fdp sicht
sehr guter kompromiss
matthias gastel hat für die grünen mit
verhandelt jetzt muss er das ergebnis
irgendwie verkaufen wir als grüne
verkehrs leute hätten uns natürlich
gerne ein grün geführtes ministerium
gewünscht müssen und werden aber
natürlich mit dem fdp
bundesverkehrsminister gute
zusammenarbeit
gut zusammenarbeiten
der designierte verkehrsminister volker
wissing ließ am wochenende wissen
die fdp dafür sorge tragen dass höhere
energiesteuern auf diese kraftstoffe
durch geringere kfz steuern ausgeglichen
werden ich habe mir schon ein bisschen
die augen gerieben dass jemand
designierter verkehrsminister würden als
erstes die nachricht setzt jetzt müssen
die autofahrer entlastet werden das ist
nicht das was wir miteinander vereinbart
haben und daran werden wir nach erinnert
das umweltbundesamt jedenfalls erinnert
daran dass der verkehrssektor zitat in
den vergangenen jahrzehnten seine
treibhausgasemissionen nicht mindern
konnte um die klimaziele doch noch zu
erreichen fordert die behörde keine
neuzulassungen von pkw mit
verbrennungsmotor spätestens zwischen
2002 und 30 und 35
ein generelles tempolimit von 120
stundenkilometern auf autobahnen und die
subventionierung von dienstwagen soll ab
2022 schrittweise abgebaut werden doch
der koalitionsvertrag spiegelt das nicht
wider umweltverbände wehren sich jürgen
resch von der deutschen umwelthilfe hat
schon diese fahrverbote per klage
durchgesetzt jetzt will er erneut vor
gericht ziehen
der koalitionsvertrag im verkehrsbereich
ist schlichtweg verfassungswidrig weil
er eben entgegen den vorgaben des
bundesverfassungsgericht in der von uns
mit erstrittenen entscheidungen vom
april für den verkehrsbereich einfach
keine wirklich messbaren reduktion der
co2-emissionen bringt auch keine
einstieg in die verkehrstechnik
die verkehrswende sie war ein teil
grüner identität und hat es doch nicht
in die politische realität geschafft
nach 16 jahren auf oppositionskurs
scheint es als würden die grünen in der
regierung ziemlich unsanft ausgebremst